und ich habe auch ganz schön puls und
zwar wenn ich an einen mann denke
nämlich an claus weselsky
jetzt werden sich die frage stellen wer
ist in dieser mann deshalb zeigen wir
ihnen den x das ist der chef der
lokführergewerkschaft und dieser mann
hat heute bekannt gegeben dass er am
montag wieder streiken lässt falls die
bahn nicht mit einem angebot daher kommt
dass ihnen passt ich finde es absolut
verwerflich und ich finde es auch
ehrlich gesagt asozial und in zeiten
einer pandemie von ist auch noch
unsolidarisch weil sie wissen ja die
wenigen züge die dann fahren die sind
proppevoll so dass auch crooner regeln
nicht eingehalten werden kann am
dreistesten finde ich aber dass dieser
mann das alles anzettelt wie ein
geiselnehmer geiselnehmer verhandeln
nämlich nicht geiselnehmer verfügen und
genau das macht der stadt sich an den
verhandlungstisch zu setzen und die
kleinen unterschiede die es noch gibt in
den positionen zu bereinigen in der
nachtsitzung nimmt er ein ganzes land
als geiseln ich finde das absurd es regt
mich richtig auf es erinnert mich auch
an arbeitskampf techniken von vor 200
jahren für mich ist klaus wir selbst
gehen dampflok unterwegs ins neunzehnte
jahrhundert und da kann da von mir aus
auch gleich bleiben
also den ärger kann ich gut verstehen
war viel bahn also das ist wirklich ja
ich glaube das geht das geht millionen
in deutschland zu nur wenn man sich
fragt wie kann man das eigentlich ändern
oder was ist in der tiefer liegenden
grund dafür dann ist es im grunde
genommen das ergebnis eine
monopolstruktur wir haben eine
marktbeherrschende stellung der
deutschen bahn auch noch ein
staatsunternehmen und was drauf los dass
das staatsunternehmen dass ich überhaupt
und ja es ist überfällig dass wir dort
mal privatisieren wettbewerb eröffnen
das wäre so wie wenn wir immer noch ein
handy unternehmen hätten und deutsche
telekom würde uns bestimmen die
handytarife oder ein gewerkschaftsführer
der telekom würde uns wir telefonieren
gerade mal abschalten also
marktbeherrschende stellung ist nicht
nur ein thema von konzernleitungen
sondern eben auch von gewerkschaftsseite
tm ist braucht eine diese
marktbeherrschende stellung und das
ändern wir am besten als gesellschaft
wenn wir den wettbewerb auf machen warum
ist das warum gibt es bei der bahn so
schwer weil es ein staatsbetrieb ist und
die telekom auch und
privatisieren warum nach und man hat ja
gesehen wie sich die telekom zu einem
modernen unternehmen gewandelt von einem
bern apparat zu einem modernen
unternehmen und genauso muss muss espada
passiert ich habe keine fantasie wie
diese bahn irgendwann einmal ein zu
einem modernen mobilität unternehmen
werden die züge sind schon ganz okay
also jedenfalls die ics oder aber die
ganze denken doch das ist doch das ist
doch ein riesenapparat
japan sich veranstaltung da da fehlt der
unternehmerische mut die fantasie und
ich bin völlig hier wolframs meinung da
muss wettbewerb her die schiene kann er
beim staat bleiben aber die anbieter
müssen im wettbewerb unterschiedliche
angebote machen das wird zum nutzen der
kunden hier sich auswirken und und dann
bis muss noch eines vor augen halten
denn die über mobilitäts wende sprechen
ja die grünen wollen ja noch viel mehr
verkehr auf die auf die schiene bringen
und die waren weiter ausbauen ja ich
sage jetzt ist dieser beamtenapparat
waren heute schon total überlastet ja
was soll da noch ausgebaut werden wie
soll das gehen in welchem jahrzehnt bis
20.15 sollen wie viele kilometer gleise
irgendwohin ich habe also eine völlig
eine völlig illusorisch
vorstellung dass diese bahn in dieser
starts wirtschaftlichen verfassung noch
irgendwas zu einer modernen mobilitäts
wenn du jetzt frage ich mir in diesem
tarif kampf sozusagen wie geht man dann
mit einem wie weselsky
also ich meinte er sagt halt ganz
einfach entweder es kommt so wie ich
will oder wir fahren mal wieder nicht
hat das kennen der von stalin ungefähr
nadal in der gewerkschaften hier und ich
reg mich da genauso auf wie du das ist
unmöglich wird er das land in geiselhaft
nimmt aber man kann sich ja jetzt
rechnen das gibt der flextreme habe ich
gerade probiert aus hamburg hat super
funktioniert also ich ärger mich jetzt
so über die bahn dass ich jetzt immer
öfters flextreme fahren würde war ich
denke das ist dann vielleicht mal ein
adventure für diese gute es ist ja schon
so eine art von also mini mini mini mini
mini konkurrenz auf dem eigenen bei den
fernbussen haben das gesehen wir haben
uns sehr gewundert als vor zehn jahren
die fernbusse liberalisiert wurden
damals gewundert wieso haben wir nicht
jahrzehnte davor das vermuten bekommen
wie so durfte man nicht mit dem bus von
hamburg nach frankfurt fahren und die
liberalisierung hat nichts gekostet aber
sie hat millionen von menschen neue
möglichkeiten eröffnen florierendes
geschäft es ist auch noch günstig für
eine junge generation eine tolle sache
da sieht man wie liberalisierung
funktioniert allerdings unterliegen wir
sehen dass sie alle dann auch das gefühl
habe dass du markt dann die preise für
die nutzer nach unten bringen das könnte
auch sein dass der markt bahn fahren
noch teurer an der hoover haben es
gesehen lufthansa war monopolist
wettbewerb gibt sind die preise gesunken
aber es ist ein bus fahren so viel 15
euro 20 nach barcelona zu fliegen ist
also ok ist die soziale wohltat dann
können sie es auch viele leisten aber da
klingelt da klingelt ihr jetzt so ist
der selber lachen klingt jetzt an mir
sozusagen einen grünen reflex an
irgendwo muss ja dann auch nur sagen wir
mal der preis bremse nach unten seien
die folge das ist doch das reiche gottes
unternehmens wenn die damit halbwegs
wirtschaft kommen können und nicht in
insolvenz geraten wenn sie also
niemanden mit in den wirtschaftlichen
abgrund nehmen dann könnte es auch für 0
euro anbieten war nicht dass wir morgen
mit grünem strom fliegen und das umwelt
argument sozusagen keines mehr die
preise sind trotzdem 19 euro nach
mallorca wird noch so freuen doch
eigentlich nur also dass etwas möglich
ist und für jedermann verfügbar ist auch
eine soziale
ich bin zwar wirklich politisch alles
andere als grün aber da geht es mir
lieber da habe ich auch jemanden mit
einem grünen reflex fall dass das kann
es nicht sein dass man vernahm
irgendwohin pflegt das finde ich nicht
aber deren zahl vielleicht 190 oder 200
er kalkuliert das doch es ist doch
besser wenn noch auf aufs mal in den
letzten fünf minuten irgendwelche leute
für 19 euro was buchen als dass die
sitze leerbleiben aber dann bleiben ja
die flugzeuge werden ja immer mehr in
der frequenz wenn die den erfolg haben
denke ich mal also wenn wenn wenn es
nicht so gut wenn es nicht so billig ist
dann wird ja auch nicht genommen werden
und dann wird es auch nicht angeboten
was genau wir mit dem billigen schnitzel
wenn du ein schweinesteak nackensteak
für 155 anbietet wird gekauft und das
sind beide gleich schuld die das
produzieren und dieses konto mehr das
macht durch mike wirtschaftlicher jetzt
fertig
jetzt wollte ja wirklich wie heißt es
doch kein argument gegen ein problem des
produktes wenn das produkt fliegen das
problem hat das ist die umwelt schädigt
dann muss man das verbessern zum
beispiel indem man emissionsfrei fliegt
was ist denn wenn wir in fünf jahren
emissionsfrei fliegen in norwegen
fliegen die ersten flieger mit ökostrom
grüner strom keine emission warum sollen
die denn nicht für 19 euro nach mallorca
das geht kann er aber also dann sehen
wir das fliegen und der preis ist nicht
das problem einer ich glaube dass die
schwierigkeit ist wenn 19 euro sich
etablieren als rentabler preis für die
airline dann fliegen alle 30 sekunden
flieger nach mallorca nie im leben dann
und dann ja dann tritt ja dieses
ökologische thema ja ja ja kaum aber wie
im leben rentiert sich ein flair für 19
euro doch klar ja das wird nicht weil
die benzinkosten damit zahlt dann nicht
weil die landegebühr ja klar nicht das
heißt andere müssen höhere höhere preise
2 und zwar diejenigen die sich das
privilegien nehmen eben vorher zu
reservieren und zu sagen ich will mich
darauf ja aber wir selbst gegnerin
flugbetrieb muss was wir bis jetzt
gesehen ich muss die debatte
zurückziehen zu wollen also erstens den
stalin vergleich der musik wirklich von
mir weisen bei star lesen sind die züge
damals ja leider wirklich gefahr sales
[Gelächter]
und zweitens ich glaube die debatte
zeigt dass man bisher wirklich dankbar
sein muss weil wir diskutieren jetzt
über all das und ich glaube die debatte
wird sich in deutschland ausbreiten dass
das mit der bahn einfach so nicht
funktionieren und wenn man weiterhin um
die bahn setzen wird als absolute als
absoluten monopol konzern dann wird das
ja auch weiter so gehen je mächtiger die
band wird desto mächtiger wird ja auch
wesselsky und desto mehr werden
innovative möglichkeiten eingeschränkt
deswegen ich bin man ehrlich gesagt
dankbar also ich will noch einmal
korrigieren zu meiner these danke klaus
bis sales geht das muss einmal gesagt
werden hat er gewartet
[Musik]